كارثه الرحله 571
اكلو جثث اصدقاءهم ومنهم من اقتسم لحوم
بعض اقاربه ماساه رحله الانديز واقتراف
ابشع تصرف بشري
في صباح يوم 13 من اكتوبر من عام
1972 اقلعت الرحله رقم 571 من مدينه
مونتفيديو في الاوروجواي متجهه الى دوله
تشيلي كانت الاجواء مثاليه جدا داخل
الطائره بين ركبها الذي كانوا فريقا
رياضيا لكن سوء الاحوال الجويه اوقف
الرحله في الارجنتين القولون
الخوليوبيراداس قبطان الطائره اسرع على
الاقناع بعد مرور ليله واحده ورغم الظروف
الجويه القاسيه اقلعت الطائره متوجهه نحو
مصيرها المجهول القبطان في راداس اخطا
التقدير عندما اظن انه عبر وتجاوز قمم
الانديز الشائعه فخفض من ارتفاع الطائره
ومع الغيوم الشديده والمنخفضه الجويه
القاسيه دخلت حركه الطائره وفاقد السيطره
عليها ووقعت الكارثه
اصطدم جناح الطائره الايمن باحدى القمم
الجبليه بعدها مباشره فقدت الطائره جناحها
الايسر بسبب قمه جبليه اخرى ومع تخلق لجسم
الطائره انخلع ذيلها وهو بين جبال الانديز
وبه عدد من الركاب
45 راكبا توفي منهم 29 راكبا وجميع اعضاء
الطاقه
ونجاحينها 16 شخصا قضوا اياما مرعبه
وباردا
لقد سقطوا في منطقه نائيه لا زرع فيها
ولمياء ولا اي مظهر من مظاهر الحياه ان
نجون اصبحوا منعزلين بدون اكل على ارتفاع
ثلاثه الاف و600 متر حيث بداوا يبحثون عن
طوق نجاه خصوصا بعد عدم وصول اي فرق انقاذ
بعد انقطاع الامل في النجاه ومرور نحو
شهرين علينا قررت ان رفقه صديق اخر شقه
جبال الانديز للوصول الى النجده وبعد 10
ايام من المشي قطعنا فيها اكثر من 100 كلم
وصلنا لمنطقه تقابل حافه احد الانهار
وجدهما الحكم او راكب الخيل
لقد اصبح راكب الخيل التشيلي سيرجيو كتلن
طوق النجاه الاخير بعدما حمل برساله من
المفقودين واسرع في ابلاغ السلطات التي
بالفعل قامت بارسال فرق الانقاذ وبعد مرور
72 يوما من وقوع الحادثه تم ايجاد الناجين
بالنسبه
المكان
القتلى كان من الممكن ان اكون جثه بينهم
لقد شكرت الله طيرت هذه السنوات ال 40
قصير
لكن الفاجعه في هذه الحادثه ما ارتكبه
البعض منهم تجاه جثث اصدقائهم فالجوعوا في
قلب جبال الانديز البارده جعلهم يفكرون في
اي طريقه من اجل البقاء فصوتوا على اكل
لحوم رفاقهم الذين حفظت اجسادهم بين
الثلوج بعضهم اشترط عدم البدء باكل شقيقته
او امه فكانت تصويت على الشخص الابعد من
ناحيه القرابه او الصداقه
فاصبحت جثه قائد الطائره اول مادبه طعام
لهم وبعد مرور سنوات على هذه الحادثه افصح
البعض عن ما ارتكبوه من فعله شنعاء تجاه
اجساد زملاءهم
[موسيقى]